so we just got the latest data on the UK
economy the state of the economy GDP
here it is this is showing you the big
picture of a gross domestic product the
size of the economy it's the level here
you can see the pandemic there that big
fall and the latest numbers show it's
0.2 growth uh in April but the thing I
want you to focus on is basically that
line we're kind of back at pre-pandemic
levels just about but essentially we're
flatlining and most economists think
it's going to carry on that way not
necessarily shrinking but if there is
even a slight deviation we could well be
in recession and the reason that matters
is we'll look at what's happening in the
mortgage market right now now these are
the average rates that people are paying
if you're reflexing your mortgage 5.54
this chart goes all the way back to the
1960s you can see there a bit higher for
two-year rate mortgages and it doesn't
look like it's very high does it that
line over there but higher since 2008
but here's the thing you've got to
adjust for the fact these are just the
headline mortgage rates just for the
fact that you have higher mortgages
right now people are more indebted they
have lower incomes in comparison with
their mortgages and just for all of that
and it's a very different picture you
get a very different line an effective
rate really showing the burden that
people are facing going all the way back
to the 1960s and have a look where we
are right now is actually the highest
since 1991 and remember 1991 official
rates were up at 13 that precipitated a
housing crash a recession where we're
kind of getting up towards those levels
right now and we might get there we
might even exceed it why we'll have a
look at what's happened to interest rate
expectations so this is a future
interest rate expectations for the bank
of England they've gone up an awful lot
because inflation has been a lot higher
than expects a lot higher than the bank
expected by the way they've just
announced they're going to do an
external review of their inflation
forecasting in the face of criticism
this is what was expected only last
month so rates were gonna Peak around
4.75 in the next few years just look at
how that's changed now the expectation
is they're going up to 5.75 so closing
in on six percent by the end of the year
the turn of next year that is really
high and that's yet to feed through to
those mortgage charts I showed you a
moment ago so things could get really
tough for you particularly if you have a
mortgage